tesla recently announced a new and
improved giga press for their cyber
truck production line and i believe it
is a game changer for the automobile
industry so what is this new machine all
about and why is this so important for
tesla stick around as i discuss that in
this video what is gigapress before we
get into the new cybertruck giga press
let's look at what a gigapress actually
is if you're unfamiliar with the tesla
manufacturing process all its cars
batteries and other ancillary products
are manufactured in giant factories
known as gigafactories tesla currently
operates five giga factories gigafactory
one two and five are located in the us
while three is located in china and four
in germany gigafactories allow tesla to
control the entire production process of
their vehicles from the raw materials to
the finished product this vertical
integration helps to keep costs down and
improve quality control if you ever get
a chance to roam the floors of a
gigafactory you can really see why elon
keeps repeating that for tesla the
factory is the actual product anyways
these gigafactories are also some of the
world's largest car assembly lines and
packs some of the most innovative
automobile production technology the
world has ever seen one such technology
is the gigapress a behemoth of a machine
that die-cast aluminum to create the
main chassis elements of a tesla car
each tesla production line has several
of these machines which are integral to
the overall manufacturing of tesla
vehicles in simple terms a giga press is
a massive machine used to stamp out
entire sections of cars in one go if you
had ever played with toy cars or lego
bricks you would have held a die cast of
material without realizing it most toys
are made using a method known as
injection molding and die casting this
is where hot molten plastic is injected
into molds or dyes and once cooled out
pops the solid shape of the toy it is a
very effective way of mass manufacturing
plastic goods in effect this is the same
principle applied in a gigapress however
on a much larger scale and it is molten
aluminum alloy instead of plastic these
kinds of metal presses have been in the
automobile sector for years still they
were generally used to make smaller
parts of the car which were then
assembled together to form the entire
structure not satisfied with this elon
and tesla's engineers took it to a whole
nother level with their giga presses for
the first time ever they created a
machine that allowed an automobile
manufacturer to cast an entire vehicle
segment in one go speeding up the
manufacturing process by orders of
magnitude these new giga presses are 20
meters long 7.5 meters tall and 6 meters
wide they're so big that they require
over 20 flatbed trucks to transport just
one these machines weigh more than 400
tons and can apply a clamping force of
over 61 000 kilonewtons equivalent to
over 6100 tons of pressure per square
foot molten aluminum alloy weighing
approximately 80 kilograms or 180 pounds
is injected into the super chill casting
mold at 10 meters per second or 22 miles
per hour the press is then closed and it
takes the machine around 80 to 90
seconds to complete the casting once the
casting is complete the segment is
removed and the open mould is cooled to
a temperature of 185 degrees celsius or
365 degrees fahrenheit a fresh batch of
molten aluminum alloy is prepared for
the next cycle to begin one to two
minutes after the first cycle this
insane process continues over and over
again allowing the gigapress to reach an
output rate of 40 to 45 completed
castings per hour which translates to
more than 1 000 castings per day and
what's more the entire process is
automated and not a single human is
required to operate a giga press
specially designed robots lubricate the
mold at the beginning of each cycle then
a separate one injects the molten alloy
into the mold another robot reaches in
and removes the casting after the
process is complete and quenches it in a
water tank while a different robot
cleans the mold and prepares it for the
next cycle the finished casting is then
handed over to another robot which puts
it through a mechanical press that trims
off the excess aluminum and rounds the
edges the casting is then x-rayed for
quality control and a final laser guided
cnc robot drills in all the holes that
will be used to assemble it with other
sections to form the body of the car if
this is not impressive enough for you
imagine a row of giga presses producing
different castings of different parts of
the car all at the same time then
handing them over to a column of fully
automated robots that assemble the
various pieces together to build the
car's final shape and all this is done
before a human hand even touches the
vehicle now that is true automation the
invention of the gigapress has been one
of the most innovative technologies
developed in the automotive sector since
henry ford first invented the assembly
line it replaces the age-old tradition
of automobile manufacturers casting
smaller components and bolting hundreds
of them together to form the chassis
instead with the development of the
gigapress tesla only has to deal with
three major chassis components the front
and rear structures and the car bed that
houses the battery pack this makes
production extremely efficient safe and
fast the gigapress is just one example
of the company's commitment to
innovation and unique approach to
manufacturing but we all know by now
that elon will not be happy with just
one creation so tesla engineers have
gone even beyond this time around when
talking about how the first giga presses
came about in an interview elon said
when we were trying to figure this out
there were six major press manufacturers
in the world we called each one of them
five said no and one said maybe and we
said great let's go with the maybe so we
went with the maybe and it worked out
well this company was the idro group an
italian company known for its
die-casting machines the company already
had massive die-casting machines in its
catalogue but elon was looking for
something even bigger so working
together with tesla engineers they
created the first customized giga
presses for tesla's fairmont factory
called dcm 1 and 2. both these presses
became operational in late 2020 and were
responsible for model-wise single-piece
rear casting the next evolution of the
gigapress saw the development of the
ol6100cs models for tesla's german
gigafactory and the impress plus dcc
6000 models for its chinese gigafactory
both these machines can stamp out not
just the rear segment but also the front
and the entire crash structure of the
model y as a single piece then in early
2021 elon announced that for the
production of the cyber truck tesla
would need an even bigger gigapress with
a clamping force of over 8 000 tons and
after months of teasing in late may of
2022 we finally got confirmation of this
new giga press when idra tweeted a video
showing the assembly of its new 9000 ton
gigapress machine this new cybertruck
gigapress is the biggest and most
powerful stamping machine that idra has
ever built although not a whole lot is
known about this 9000 ton gigapress it
is explicitly designed to stamp out the
structures of the new tesla cyber truck
which is due to come to market next year
with the potential for production to
start near the end of 2022 but what i
know from inside sources is that this
new model of gigapress will be able to
stamp out the entire rear body the truck
bed and the crash structure as single
sections making the cyber truck
production line the fastest and the most
efficient of any other vehicle in the
tesla lineup my sources also say that
the new model will be capable of
stamping out body parts for other tesla
models at an unprecedented rate
improving the cycle speed up to 10 times
faster than the traditional 6 000 ton
giga presses depending on the segment
now that will be an enormous improvement
with this new technology tesla will
definitely plan to ramp up the
production of their highly anticipated
electric vehicles including the cyber
truck model 3 and model y this makes
perfect sense to me given tesla's future
goals and the demand for their cars
rising worldwide so maybe introducing
this new giga press will not only help
the production of the cyber truck and
other tesla models but it will finally
make the 25 000 tesla model which elon
had promised us a reality with this new
giga press tesla can significantly
reduce the cost of production by
stamping out entire segments of cars at
one go and also speed up the whole
assembly process so there is no reason
why that elusive common man's cheap
tesla model can't be a reality in the
near future but either way i think this
new giga press from tesla is truly a
game changer in the automotive industry
i mean this machine is a gigantic leap
forward it is so beyond the capabilities
of other existing presses in the market
that it will give tesla an enormous
manufacturing edge over its competitors
as if that was not enough even the next
best press in the market is a tesla
gigapress so you can see that unless
other legacy car manufacturers like
toyota or volkswagen can develop better
manufacturing technologies or
incorporate these gigapresses into their
own assembly lines then they will be
left behind and probably never be able
to catch up with tesla that's it from me
what do you think about tesla's new
gigantic giga press do you think it'll
be a game changer for tesla in the
coming years let me know in the comment
section below also don't forget to hit
subscribe and like the video if you
enjoyed the content thank you for
watching and come back for more